the ending of Avengers infinity war
raised a lot of questions for the future
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
especially the fourth Avengers movie set
to premiere in May 2019 it's impossible
to talk about this movie without getting
into spoilers so if you still somehow
haven't seen infinity war well let Mark
Ruffalo fill you in wait till you see
this next one everybody do the knows his
quest to retrieve the six stones of the
Infinity Gauntlet ends with fatal
consequences
for many of Earth's Mightiest Heroes
with characters being thrown off cliffs
strangled exploded and ultimately turned
into ash
but as dire as the ending seems it's
unlikely that all those dearly departed
heroes will stay that way for long
especially considering many of the
supposedly deceased have already been
confirmed to appear in Avengers 4
whether it's via flashback time travel
or convenient resurrection it's clear
that many of our favorite fallen heroes
will be returning from the grave well
the question of how remains mysterious
here's a rundown of all the superheroes
confirmed to return for Avengers 4
ant-man ant-man appears have made it out
alive by simply not showing up after
sitting out the events of Avengers
infinity war Paul Rudd Scott Lang will
be back in action for the fourth team up
movie as far as Black Widow knows an
infinity war Scott was busy caring for
his family and being under house arrest
at the time of Thanos invasion we'll
learn more about where he is exactly in
ant-man in the wasp the story of which
could potentially even provide a segue
to his role in Avengers 4 since Rudd was
spotted on the set of the team-ups
production it's safe to say he plays at
least a small part in the big story
black panther chadwick boseman x' -
Charla was one of the most surprising
characters to bite the dust at the end
of infinity war though his exit was
shocking Bozeman's presents on the
atlantis set for Avengers 4 suggests
some relatively hasty return considering
the fact that Black Panther standalone
film made over 1 billion dollars of the
box-office and has a sequel in the works
it seemed safe to assume the king of
Wakanda will find his way back from the
necropolis in Avengers 4 Black Widow
Black Widow is one of the few characters
who survived the events of infinity war
so it's only natural that she come back
for round 2 and this time to have a
bigger role to play screenwriters
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
have acknowledged that black widow ends
up slightly sidelined in infinity
and indicated that they couldn't afford
to give her as much screen time as fans
might have liked they felt comfortable
pushing her into the background because
they knew there would be more to come
but both her and Captain America
according to Marcus we realized that far
more potential in the movie coming next
year just in terms of how the characters
would be tested by the story Captain
America Chris Evans has been planning
his exit from the MCU for a while now
and it's highly likely that Avengers 4
will mark his swan song as Captain
America like a black widow
it appears he'll have more to do in the
story and the next go-round intriguing
set pictures not only showed Evans on
the set of the fourth movie but also
wearing his old costume from the first
Avengers from a plot standpoint the
implications are fascinating are we
gonna see cap get up to some time travel
will there be two Captain America's
running around on the different suits or
how we tell them apart
wait is that way black widows blonde no
Captain Marvel
we won't get the chance to officially
meet pre-license Captain Marvel until
the carrots a standalone film comes out
in March 2019 but we did get our first
tease of our entry into the MCU a thanks
to infinity Wars post-credits scene
considering that so many of the MC use
of the heroes are currently out of
commission it's a sure bet that Captain
Marvel will help save the day in
Avengers 4 one way or another
photos reportedly from the set of the
movie revealed a sporting a green
variation of a costume and Josh Brolin a
study shot at least one scene with
Larson for the infinity war stories
conclusion falcon Anthony Mackey's
Falcon may have been snapped out of
existence at infinity war but he has
already assured fans I he'll be back for
the fourth film sharing a picture of
himself relaxing on the movie sets
Mackie's even gone so far as to offer up
a bit of plot summary for fans in an
interview with MTV a lot of people
fighting whole lot of people talking
it's a war of infinite proportions cut
the check
Gamora Gamora played by Zoe Saldana met
a particularly tragic end in infinity
war with Thanos sacrificing his adopted
daughter in order to obtain the soul
stone
considering that her demise occurred
prior to Thanos his universe culling
snap it's a plot Turner seemed like it
might stick that is until Saldana
appeared to say otherwise speaking to e
news Saldana said her last day on the
set of infinity war didn't feel like
goodbye but to be continued the comments
seemed to confirm her
Almond in the fourth film even if it
doesn't necessarily mean gomorrah will
be coming back to life maybe she'll be
glimpsed in flashback or stuck in a
strange dimension inside of the soul
stone
whatever the specifics it sure looks
like she'll be back Hawkeye fans were
heartbroken over the absence of Jeremy
Renner's Hawkeye from Avengers infinity
war you never know his bow and arrow
could have made the difference
like can't man Hawkeye was said to have
taken a house arrest deal with the
government following the events of
Captain America Civil War retiring from
avenging to spend time with his family
but Renner has confirmed that he filmed
for Avengers for more intriguingly the
actor was spotted on set with a new
haircuts covering up a costume that
looks suspiciously like the superhero
ronin an identity his character
temporarily assumed in the comics
regardless of which name he goes by the
screenwriters have promised that Hawkeye
will be a big part of the fourth film
telling BuzzFeed we like Hawkeye we like
Hawkeye so much we gave him a really
good story
Hulk Mark Ruffalo's Bruce Banner had
some performance issues in the third
Avengers movie but at least he made it
out alive after spending a whole movie
and able to summon the Hulk it seems
fair to expect that his powers will be
returned to him at some point in part
four Ruffalo has said that thor ragnarok
and the third and fourth Avengers films
are designed to form one Hulk storyline
over three installments and it's a story
likely to end with a bang Ruffalo was
also spotted on set in a motion capture
suit so either he's still inside that
Hulk buster or the big green guy is
coming back Iron Man if you believe the
rumors and Avengers 4 could be the end
of Tony Stark although Robert Downey jr.
hasn't shared any information and
whether or not his character will make
it through Avengers 4 he has been one of
the more outspoken cast members when it
comes to hyping the film on social media
from all the photos he shared of his
involvement in the movies production we
know for sure that he will appear
whether he makes it out alive well
that's another story
mantas like most of the guardians of the
galaxy from Clemente s Manchester's
integrated at the end of infinity war
the main TF though has already seemingly
confirmed that she'll be back on board
for Avengers for sharing a photo of her
makeup trailer on social media it
doesn't tell us anything about where
she's gone or how she's coming back but
it does show a Lisa Mantis will be
returning for the next Avengers
additionally Chris Pratt revealed in an
Instagram post
he'll be filming guardians of the galaxy
volume 3 will fire in 2019 it seems like
Avengers 4 has no choice but to get
things back on track for the spacefaring
team before their next adventure
nebula Karen Gillan's nebula didn't
exactly have a smooth ride through
infinity war but she was one of the few
characters that survived the trip
not only will nebula be back for
Avengers 4 Gillan has shared a hope that
I character will be able to somehow face
her daddy issues head-on in the film for
what it's worth nebula was also very
important to defeating Thanos and the
comic book version of the story telling
the tide of battle by stealing the
gauntlet for herself whether she makes
the same move in the movie or not
infinity war perfectly sets up nebulas
Avengers for arc for adamson and revenge
Scarlet Witch elizabeth olsen Scala
which ended the movie being thoroughly
defeated forced to watch visions life
and not just once but twice before being
defeated herself wander is confirmed to
come back to finish the fight in
Avengers 4 with Olsen sharing a pic of a
bruise she received on the set during a
flying scene he is hoping we get to see
the powerful Avenger really unleashed a
chaos in the fourth movie with the love
of her life being taken out so cruelly
by Thanos she's never had more to avenge
spider-man Tom Hollands spider-man had
one of the most brutal disappearing
scenes in infinity war but it's one that
has the least impact when you know
what's going on behind the scenes
we've known for some time that Holland
will be suiting up as Peter Parker again
for a second standalone film which is
set to hit theaters just a few months
after Avengers falls release we also
know that he's part of Avengers 4
because he reportedly broke his nose on
the set of the production who said
acting was easy huh broken nose number
three what a way to finish a movie
fallows will pay for this one for Chris
Hemsworth Thor spent most of infinity
war getting back to full power
and you can bet he'll put that power to
good use in Avengers 4 despite the fact
that the character got a stylish haircut
in Thor Ragnarok Hemsworth was spotted
onset sporting the characters old long
head look which again employs either a
flashback or some time trouble in store
for the god of thunder vision Paul
Bettany's vision got it the worst of
anyone in infinity war getting brutally
put out to pasture not just once but
twice despite the fact that the mine
stone that gives him life is now in bed
in Thanos his gauntlet Bettany has
confirmed that he'll be back on board
for the 4th movie the actor shared a
picture of himself in full vision
regalia complete with mine stone in late
2017 filling out paperwork on the set of
Avengers for while it seems safe to
assume that vision we'll end up having
to do more than just push paper around
when he comes back it remains unclear
how he'll factor into the story
maybe Shuri managed to back up his
memory after all and he can just go back
to being Iron Man's Butler again war
machine Don Cheadle's war machine is one
of the most tenacious Avengers always
managing to bounce back from what looks
like certain doom as one of the few
survivors of infinity war the Iron Man's
sidekick will be needed more than ever
both Josh Brolin and Gwyneth Paltrow
have said that they share scenes with
Cheadle and Avengers for making his
involvement over certain Thanos is still
out there after all
roadies Gatling gun has some work left
to do wasp Evangeline Lily's hope Van
Dyne is finally suiting up to headline
the relatively light-hearted ant-man and
the wasp it's one of the two Marvel
films slated to be released between
infinity war and Avengers 4 and leads up
to an appearance by the wasp in the 2019
team-up while lady herself was confirmed
that she'll be a part of the fourth
movie he's also said that you shouldn't
expect too much of her in the film
according to a Q&A on her Instagram page
she's not going to be in it a turn
however she did say that she's proud and
stoked to be on board for the movie
adding that she had so much fun on the
film set that's what happens when you
show up just in time for the happy
ending Winter Soldier
Sebastian Stan's Bucky Barnes has had
quite the journey in the MCU
as his friendship with Steve Rogers has
been tested by time mind control and
more more this made his last moments in
infinity war or the more heartbreaking
neither we nor Steve have seen the end
of Bucky Barnes yet while Stan's remains
tight-lipped about how his character
could be coming back he has confirmed
that he films scenes for Avengers 4 the
actor has kept silent about the role
he'll play in the sequel story but we
certainly know what we want to say if
Chris Evans really is leaving after his
next movie well someone's gonna be
around to pick up the shield thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]